toujours
[Musique]
en ce moment le pays d'occupation qui
est israël utilise ses forces et ses
colons pour expulser les palestiniens de
leurs maisons et les mettre à la rue
alors pourquoi est-ce que le monde garde
le silence à ce sujet nous demandons au
gouvernement du canada de cesser de
soutenir l'armée israélienne de cesser
de soutenir l'épuration qui a lieu en
palestine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous manifestons maintenant contre les
massacres raciste qui sont commis contre
le peuple palestinien et en soutien aux
jeunes d'al aqsa et du quartier de
sheikh jarrah et d'autre de jérusalem à
jaffa haïfa
nous voulions simplement envoyer un
message en tant que jeune homme libanais
et arabes pour dire que nous essayons
autant que possible d'être solidaires de
nos frères
oui
[Applaudissements]
non
manas